hi YouTube Dan Shapiro here a director
of the Harvard international negotiation
program so it's Sunday Davos is closing
up and I've been reflecting upon some of
the key points key takeaways from my
time here I you know it's an incredibly
diverse group of people this year
everybody from mctaggart a dozen 22 to
Bill Gates to President Perez and one
big takeaway it may sound cliche and
like a platitude but it's that these
leaders are human beings and at the end
of the day they have their own
vulnerabilities and for better or worse
you know my sense is that they really
are trying to deal with the nature of
the problems that are in front of them I
also felt a serious and substantial
struggle from these leadership in how to
lead in this world which has completely
changed over the past 10 15 years where
power is much more evenly distributed
where protests in Egypt can change the
phone in Tunisia can ultimately change
the face of the entire Middle East how
do leadership effectively lead in this
completely different era than the
post-world War two ERA of leadership I
think one of the most useful things that
we as the global community could do now
is to work together to think through
what our new models of leadership how do
we work together and how do people work
together at all levels of the systems
around the world to support the better
world that we know is possible so thanks
so much look forward to continued
conversation